people say candy corn is the bottom of
the barrel disgusting offensive more of
a trick than a treat it's time to stop
this madness
candy corn tastes the way a hug feels
candy corn is the one friend who will
always make out with you when you're
lonely it's making vegetables into candy
it's doing the Lord's work other candies
look like poop or buttons I don't want
to eat paper buttons what's that I taste
oh yeah freedom they fill in Field of
Dreams in a cornfield it's only because
they couldn't find a candy corn field
and that would have been Field of Dreams
a handful of candy corn is so many candy
corn candy corn has three colors
it supports diversity you can wear them
as teeth that Milky Way that you thought
you had it's gone it's melted candy corn
never goes bad it's ombre candy it's
chic as [ __ ] it's like eating a sunset
that's candy in the name tells you
everything you need to know I mean yeah
sure it hasn't lacks any but don't act
like you never wanted to eat a candle
Oh